even before landing the lead in bohemian
rhapsody' rami malek was an accomplished
talent and he's made an impression over
the last decade as one of Hollywood's
most intriguing young stars here are the
biggest reasons why the actor who plays
Freddie Mercury looks so familiar like
pretty much every actor who went to
Hollywood with dreams of making it big
rami malek started small his first ever
on-screen role was as an enthusiastic
Bible study participant on Gilmore Girls
in 2004 which he followed up with
one-off stints on medium Alcatraz and
believe I'm rami malek and welcome to GQ
Middle East and because of his Egyptian
background Malick was often cast as
Middle Eastern characters in series like
the Iraq war FX drama over there and
Fox's 24 if you were a kid in the
mid-2000s the reason Malick looks
familiar is because he starred in one of
the most popular family film franchises
of all time in the three a Night at the
Museum movies Ben Stiller played an
unassuming night watchman at the
American Museum of Natural History in
New York City where the historical
figures and the exhibits come to life
among them is a pharaoh from ancient
Egypt portrayed by Malik my parents gave
me this tablet some 3,000 years ago has
a magical power that brings all the
exhibits to life oh really what to do
the guy who would one day play Freddie
Mercury under plenty of makeup and
prosthetics is still recognizable only
here he acts from underneath traditional
Egyptian garb before his Emmy winning
star making work on mr. robot Malik's
initial TV breakthrough was a major role
in HBO's Emmy winning miniseries the
Pacific in 2010 not only was the story
based on real events during world war ii
but Malik's character private first
class Shelton was based on a real person
as well in a roundtable discussion in
2016 Malick credited the role with
preparing him to play more complex
people without internalizing the
emotional baggage of the character and
taking that home everyday and it
physically and psychologically really
had kind of a negative impact on Malick
broke out for good in 2015 when he
landed
the lead role of Elliot Alderson on mr.
robot started intercepting all the
traffic on your network and decided to
hack you the ambitious mysterious and
unpredictable us a series concerns the
exploits of genius hacker Elliot who has
a split personality disorder and can't
always decipher what's real and what
isn't the complicated role not only made
Malik a star it earned him an Emmy for
Outstanding Lead Actor in a dramatic
series in 2016 the brutal original 1973
film Papillon starred Steve McQueen as a
real-life early twentieth-century
criminal turned South American penal
colony resident best known by his
nickname aka the title of the movie
Papillon
which means butterfly you double-crossed
me and in 2017 Papillon got the
Hollywood remake treatment with Charlie
Hunnam as the lead while Malick played
the thoughtful and crafty dega you seem
like the kind of man who can make up his
own mind
whoo good judge of character the film
earned a small theatrical release in
North America but established Malick as
a movie star not just a TV actor part of
what makes mr. robot so intriguing is
Malik's in character narration as the
troubled Elliot Alderson just a regular
cyber security engineer I'm a vigilante
haircut by night but the actor has been
honing his voice acting skills
throughout his entire decade and a half
career one of his first acting jobs was
recording dialogue for a variety of
minor characters in the classic video
game Halo 2 he also had a run on
Nickelodeon's beloved fantasy series The
Legend of Korra as tano a role he
reprised in a video game adaptation of
the show this is going to be a
sensational season of television notably
Malik's Bojack horseman character Flip
McVicker a quirky filmmaker enjoyed a
major plot art in the fourth and fifth
season of the Netflix series is all of
this a tutti-frutti illusion covered in
sprinkles
so so so many sprinkles
[Music]